who's your character in the film in
limelight and what does she like
Ariana and she is kind of the worst of
them all
she's an actress / model and I guess a
she's just and then she she
dates three guys um she's very much so
into drugs she she does whatever
producers say she's kind of lost
completely she she thinks that if she
does everything that had producer or
that someone higher up once then she'll
end up being successful and I don't see
her ever becoming so I think she just
falls deeper and deeper into habits that
are hard to break
and yeah she's just a very scandalous um
lost a girl I'd say and the the
archetype of Ariana is common and maybe
all of us have that partners to some
degree meanwhile part whatever what
advice would you give to a real-life
Ariana let's say there was someone that
came from a small town like most people
do and had become that not everybody
takes that route but it was that
heightened version of that archetype
what would you say
I'd say if you're doing if everything
you're doing feels very wrong then it's
probably wrong like the business is a
business and it's yeah it's got dark
sides but if everything you're doing is
just manipulating and especially with
actors actors like you can sleep with as
many as you want I don't think that I
ever gonna get you anything and with
producers if they want you in something
they're gonna work with you
professionally they're not gonna
you out which my character is pretty
much being out for everything and
especially she gets so lost into
addiction and drugs and that won't help
you in any business acting modeling
anything if you're doing drugs it's only
a slippery slope so everything Arianna
is pretty negative so um and then I'd
say try to keep as professional as
possible we'll try to be true to
yourself and it's a scary City because
of you do you do feel cut down so many
young beautiful girls move out here and
they instantly get plastic surgery or
change this about themselves and that
about themselves and they lose
themselves and they try to they try to
find their self-worth and somebody else
and you can't and they try to become
somebody else and that makes you less
unique than anything
so I'd say anyone that's in Ariana's
shoes needs to take a step back and be
who they are and stay away from pretty
much any type of drugs late-night things
producers promising you things like at
3:00 in the mornings probably not
true I don't know it's a hard question
there's so I could talk for hours to an
ariana and like pray to God that she
would not do what she does
you